bonsoir à tous 1983 c'était l'année du
centenaire de la naissance de franz
kafka 1984 mais évidemment c'est l'année
de george orwell
alors j'ai pensé qu'il ne serait pas
illogique mais au contraire éclairant et
même stimulant d'associer à l'évocation
de ces deux grands écrivains disparus
un autre grand écrivain mais vivant
celui ci est présent ce soir sur le
plateau d' apostrophes millan kundera
vous est donné en hausse mais en 1929 en
tchécoslovaquie vous aurez 55 ans le 1er
avril prochain
en 1968 après l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie par les troupes
soviétiques
vous êtes devenu si j'ose dire un
écrivain est rayé de la carte puisque
vous ne pouviez publié deux livres on
avait retiré vos livres des
bibliothèques en 1975
vous vous exiler en france en 1979
eh bien vous étiez déchu de votre
nationalité par votre pays et enfin en
juillet 1981
vous étiez nationaliser français proment
dit vous êtes aujourd'hui un écrivain de
nationalité française et qui écrit dans
la langue tchèque alors quelques
nouveaux titres vos romans qui sont tous
célèbres qui ont tous été traduit dans
très nombreux angles bien évidemment
sauf dans les pays de l'est alors 1900
alors là je donne à date évidemment de
publication en france 1968 la
plaisanterie avec une préface
retentissante de louis aragon 1970
risible
il résidait à mot pardon qui ce sont des
nouvelles c'est pas un roman c'est le
solide soit pas un roman la vie est
ailleurs qui a obtenu en 79 le prix du
médicis étranger en france
en 76 la valse aux adieux en 1979 le
livre du rire et de l'oubli
et puis cette semaine donc en janvier
1984 l'insoutenable légèreté de l'être
qui en dépit de son titre est un roman
je le précise tout de suite
et tous ces ouvrages ont été publiés par
le même éditeur gallimard et tous
traduits sauf le premier la plaisanterie
par françois qui règne alors pour parler
avec vous de vos livres mais aussi comme
je l'annonçais d'orwell et de kafka j'ai
invité simon leys de votre vrai nom
patrick rich man vous êtes sinologue
professeur de littérature et de langue
chinoise à l'université de canberra en
australie vous êtes l'auteur entre
autres livres des habits neufs du
président mao d'ombrés chinoises
et puis l'année dernière de la forêt en
feu le louvre âge pour lequel vous étiez
ici et je crois que tous les
téléspectateurs qui ont vu cette
émission se rappelle traduit à votre
intervention
et puis enfin vous venez de faire
paraître cette semaine aussi aux
éditions hermann orwell où l'horreur de
la politique
et puis un critique littéraire il en
fallait bien un maurice nadeau critique
littéraire éditeur aussi et surtout
directeur de la quinzaine littéraire la
quinzaine et terrasses et 1,1
bihebdomadaire donc donc mensuel par don
bigg bimensuel qui paraît donc tous les
quinze jours voilà alors milan kundera
je vous remercie d'être venus ce soir
j'ai remarqué avant cette émission qu'on
n'aimait pas beaucoup les photographes
et je sais que vous n'aimez pas non plus
les caméras alors alors qu'est-ce que
donc je suis très sensible à ce que vous
veniez là mais quelque chose qui m'a
étonné c'est que donc vous n'aimez pas
vous montrer or il se trouve que dans
votre dans ce roman dont nous allons
parler tout à l'heure il y a une phrase
justement kim est claire là dessus vous
dites nous avons tous besoin d'être
regardés et on pourrait nous ranger en
quatre catégories selon le type de
regard sous lequel nous voulons vivre
je vous dis ce soir vous qui n'aimez pas
les caméras et les photographes et bien
dans quelle catégorie vous rangez vous
ce soir
l'info c'est un passage où je dis qu'il
ya quatre catégories durée là donc on
peut désirer n'est ce pas il ya des gens
qui désirent d'être regardée par le
public c'est à dire par beaucoup de jeux
en ligne
ce sont les gens possédés de la gloire
et de la notoriété
puis il ya des gens qui le désirent le
regard des gens concrètes qu'ils
connaissent sont ceux qui qui font sans
cesse des cocktails des dîners terrain
ensuite ce sont les gens qui ne peuvent
pas vivre sans regarder quelqu'un qu il
n est la quatrième catégorie ce sont les
gens qui vivent sous le regard de
quelqu'un qui n'est pas présent ce sont
les rêveurs par exemple je peux vivre
souris garder mon père qui est mort
parce que j'aime ça c'est pas ça voilà
vous quelle catégorie là soir nous vous
êtes normalement dans la quatrième non
notamment dans la 4g est non seulement
mystère ah bon c'est bon c'est que c'est
mon secret mais certainement pas dans la
première phase est sûrement pas là je
souffre un peu
je sais dominé ce bon vous avez vous
avez dit ce matin
à daniel rondeau journaliste à
libération où il y avait dit j'aimerais
avoir écrit tout ce que j'ai écrit sous
un pseudonyme
je ne manque pas d'ambition mais
j'aimerais rester invisible vous parliez
sérieusement je crois qu on ne sait
jamais n'est-ce pas sûrement tout sur ne
manquez pas on n'a jamais dit cette
étude absolument mais curieusement je
crois que c'est très sérieux
c'était toujours mon rêve presque des
crises sous un pseudonyme c'est très
difficile à résoudre
mystification alors vous êtes et ce que
vous approuvez votre ami alain resnais
qui est un cinéaste grand signe à ce
qu'on ne voit jamais qui n'acceptent
jamais l'interview qu'on ne peut jamais
je ne comprends très bien
je les comprends bon je disais au début
que vous êtes arrivé en france il ya
huit ans vous êtes naturalisé français
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas un danger
pour vous d'être de moins en mois
tchécoslovaque et prague oies et d'être
de plus en plus français et parisien
autrement dit est-ce que votre fidélité
peut-elle s'accommoder de ce que j'ai
évidemment du changement mais aussi de
la découverte
vous savez c il existe un certain
clichés c'est un cri ce que tout le
monde répète un jeune homme qui était
comme moi presque chassé de son pays
parce que c'est une situation qui est
considéré comme tragique elle est
tragique mais heureusement tous les
situations humains sont heureusement
paradoxe c'est toujours le paradoxe qui
ne sort et le paradoxe de la situation
et que j'ai perdu ma première potes ma
première patrie et que je suis en france
très très serré et que par exemple dans
mon travail de romancier
cet hymne c'est un âne régis
enrichissement un homme et même en ce
qui concerne de la langue parce que la
confrontation que quand vous vivez sans
cesse dans deux ans
et quand vous contrôlez sans cesse votre
langue avec la langue dans laquelle vous
êtes incessamment traduit alors comme si
deux banques se voient dans un miroir et
comme si chaque mot que vous utilisez
vous l'utilisez d'une façon
sémantiquement le plus exact c'est à
dire je ne me sens absolument pas
appauvri enrichi
mais après avoir échappé à la
normalisation tchécoslovaque enfin la
normalisation russe plutôt est ce que
vous ne risquez pas de tomber dans une
autre norvège normalisation mais
beaucoup plus subtil perverse empoisonné
est magnifique c'est je dirais la
normalisation des intellectuels français
parisien se laver parisien dans tout ce
qui est ce que vous parlez là bas
pervers exagérer ce nom et c'est à dire
c'est une normalité absolue c'est comme
ça la vie intellectuelle depuis toujours
alors ce n'est pas une normalisation
ce qui à la fois une description de la
normalité
la normalisation là-bas la destruction
de la personnalité la description des
bizarreries même la restriction du
snobisme sculptrice même le snobisme
mais un phénomène paradoxal est à la
fois dégoûtant n'est ce pas quand vous
aurez parler de kafka vous aurez
certainement beaucoup d'occasions de
parler de snobisme dans ce cas serait
certainement une très grande victime de
l'armée des snobs qui ont piétiné
quasiment détruit mais en même temps le
snobisme quelque chose de risque
sympathique n'est ce pas parce que sa
vie qu'il veut paraître intelligent qui
devait paraître mieux qu'il n'est en fin
de compte et manifeste un désir
sympathique d'être mieux qui n'est alors
il faut dire aux téléspectateurs
français qui n'ont
qui n'ont pas lu vos livres que la
musique joue un grand rôle à la fois
dans votre vie et dans votre oeuvre
et souvent on le dit c'est vrai que vos
romans sont composés comme des
symphonies ou comme des polyphonies
comme des variations enfin on peut
choisir mais il faut dire que la musique
d'abord avant d'être dans votre oeuvre a
été dans votre vie par votre père et par
vous même votre père était musique mon
père était pianiste
mon père était pianiste je crois qu'il
est un excellent pianiste mais peut-être
seulement moi qui c'est qui le pense
parce qu'il est un pianiste malheureux
il était mal est réparé ce que il s'est
consacré absolument à la propagation de
la musique moderne à son époque
stravinsky chaîne berbère thorgan h
c'est à dire la musique qui à l'époque
parce qu'à l'époque renaud binette
encore faible aujourd'hui heureusement
les snop savent écouter même saint denis
à l'époque le snobisme tellement faible
et les vrais connaisseurs de la musique
était encore plus faible alors rsa les
concerts où mon père à jouer cette
musique difficile est évident mais ça
crée chez moi une passion non seulement
pour mon père mais à travers de mon père
la passion pour l'art moderne pour la
musique moderne pour l'art moderne en
général dary pour cet art qui est qui
conte fait devant les salles qui sont
vides qu'on fait un peu contre courant
des comptes
les convainc ce oui mais vous vous avez
été j'ai vu qu'à nice de barrage ou pas
de la musique très moderne aller dans
les bars qui s'était à l'époque c'était
à l'époque tu es très dramatique ans
quand j'ai gagné ma vie parce là on a
joué n'importe quoi un espace pour que
au coeur les gens des villages dans ce
n'était même pas uncharted la musique
improvisée
alors pendant certaines écoles vous avez
gardé d un contact très très très précis
très hugo rigoureux que la musique vous
jouez toujours du piano non pas du tout
pas du tout c'est une trahison totale à
partir d'un certain moment je n'aimais
plus la musique n'est plus le milieu de
la musique
j'ai trouvé ce millier pas c'est
intéressant parce intelligente j'ai
vraiment trahi la musique mais quelque
chose m'a vraiment rester dans quand
j'écris quand j'ai quand je construis
mes romans alors ce n'est pas seulement
un cliché si on dit que s'est construit
d'une façon très musical ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire le
principe de la musique une composition
musicale
c'est le principe de la répétition et de
la variance est à dire si vous avez je
ne sais pas la forme des sonata vous
exposer le thème à le tmb le thème c'est
ensuite vous variez la tma le tmb le
terrain si vous répétez le thème le
principe de la musique de la pensée
musicale
si vous exposer un motif vous ne devez
jamais l'oublier pendant le travail vous
devez toujours revenir à ces motifs
encore une fois encore une fois le
variés et d'où une composition musicale
possède une très grande cohérence une
cohérence que le roman ne connaît pas
passer de 7 ans connaîtra cohérence très
8 août bon alors je vais composer un
petit peu mais pour boire votre jus de
fruits le
je me tourne et donc vers simon leys et
maurice nadeau j'ai commencé par simon
leys vous demandez au fond pourquoi
l'oeuvre de milan kundera vous paraît
importante
je salue tous ces livres alors connaît
quels sont les livres que vous préférez
de lui etc
vous savez quel profonde admiration j'ai
pour lettre de monsieur kundera problème
c'est que l'admiration qu'on a pour un
artiste n'est pas nécessairement
qualification pour commenter son heure
je me sens très mal qualifiés pour
commencer à pérorer sur le monsieur
qu'on dira alors que j'aurais très peur
de mettre dans la position d'un
personnage particulièrement touchante de
son oeuvre
le personnage de plus tôt dans la de le
placer dans la position de ce personnage
de son oeuvre d'être comme les les
personnages les consommateurs dans le
café où la jeune veuve tamina sert les
consommations vous appelez dans le livre
ii du rire et de l'oubli
la jeune veuve amina qui sera chauffé à
l'exil qui a perdu son mari qui est sert
les consommations dans un café les
consommateurs lui parle tout le temps
les consommateurs explique la
tchécoslovaquie les consommateurs
explique ce que sa tragédie ce caisson
et amis n'en dit rien elle écoute ce que
les gens disent et j'ai très peur
c'est kundera d'être bien sûr son regard
il faudra le faire je pense que c'est là
d'où sera déplacé pour faire ça je dis
seulement qu'il ya dans tous les thèmes
de l'oeuvre si woods a qui sont une
offre tellement tellement riche
un thème qui personnellement me touche
très particulièrement celui non
seulement qu'ils développent dans ses
livres mais qui qui est très bien repris
résumé dans un entretien qu'il avait
avec philip roth qui est publié à la fin
la traduction anglaise de du livre ii du
rire et de l'oubli
cette expérience nous paraît fondamental
que monsieur kundera a eu et que notre
civilisation est mortel que la situation
européenne est mortelle
dans la moitié de l'europe où il vivait
cette civilisation a disparu et ils
cherchent à nous raconter à nous dire
nous vivons dans un full aux paradise
dans un paradis d'imbéciles que nous
nous doutons pas que le même sort
impensable et très pas à appeler très
possible ça me paraît un indé quand un
bouleversant et je ne sais pas je me
demande d'ailleurs dans quelle mesure ce
thème est communicable dans quelle
mesure saisie oui bon alors maurice
nadeau et le relais
et bien moi je crois qu'il faudra nous
le garder un coup de dés rare que oui
nous le garder en france depuis qu il
est naturalisé français parce que je ne
sais pas s'ils n'auraient pas une
tentation américaine peut-être un an
non il est déjà honoris causa de
l'ennemi a quitté nice figure obligée
pas limité non mais je vois très bien
moelleux ancien grand prix américain ça
n'arrête pas penser que les américains
essayent de le séduire
moi je lui vois apple à la carrière de
norman mailer ou de williams tyrone par
exemple ça m'étonnerait pas du tout
c'est pourquoi je dis il faut le garder
solidement ici on va pas d'emprisonner à
je sais pas si oui n'hésitez sera pas
fermé son oeuvre
oui bien sûr ne sait quand apparut la
plaisanterie en a été
il y avait une préface d'aragon moi ça
m'a tout de suite rebuter je les lui
faisait 10 n'est pas si mal tiens à
propos de la tchécoslovaquie surtout à
propos de de kundera et c'est dans cette
préface qui parle d'ailleurs de bien
faibles de biafra de l'esprit et puis
alors dans le livre la plaisanterie y
est c'est l'histoire de ce jeune homme
qui écrit trotsky sur une carte postale
j'étais réconcilier tout de suite ses
plaisanteries c'était quand même il ya
des confusions il faut pas faire dès
l'entrée c'est de le prendre pour un
écrivain de l'est ou pour un dissident
kundera tu n'es ni l'un ni l'autre bras
tchécoslovaquie pas à l'est est au
centre d'une démocratie populaire ce
d'un fair entendu et kundera dépasse de
beaucoup
comment dire l'opposition au régime ça
fait partie de sa vie de son oeuvre
et puis s'il est ici c'est pas ça n'est
pas pour rien non plus mais il dépasse
de beaucoup ce ce statut d'écrivain
dissidents il ne dépassait pas un
militant si vous vous lille il a dépassé
par par l'envergure de ses
préoccupations
s'il n'y a que tout ce qu'il raconte ses
histoires ya beaucoup se passe dans ce
contexte
mais dès le départ aussi ce contexte et
le contexte des données le dépasse dans
la littérature le dépasse par la
littérature
par exemple on avant d'arriver à la une
des plus belles parties enfin du du
dernier livre de la légèreté de l'être
il ya de cette histoire d'amour ça beau
être en effet comme vous dites
une histoire à variation une symphonie
c'est quand même ça qui est la chose
essentielle et l'histoire tchèque au
fond enfin l'occupation russe âgé kosova
qui n'a toute son ampleur qu'à la fin du
livre je dis pas que qu'elle est sans
intérêt au contraire c'est une façon de
voir le régime comme on n'a pas encore
vu même dans le livre du rire et de
l'oubli et c'est une façon neuve de le
voir parce que nous on est en vie sur
des clichés de lui il a connu c'est la
terreur c'est le goulag c'est
l'empêchement pensée déclara il montre
que c'est pas ça le plus terrible c'est
terrible sans doute mais que derrière
devant plutôt devant tout ça il ya ce
paravent qui est la bonne conscience qui
est la joie qui est la santé qui est
vive la vie comme dit qu'elle est baisé
aux enfants qui est c'est enfin tout ce
côté qu'il appelle teach et ça c'est
très neuf oui alors ce qu'il faudrait
aussi quand même pour les encore une
fois je m'adresse pour les
téléspectateurs
enfin je vous parle pas des spectateurs
qui ne vont pas lui qu'on doit il faut
dire aussi que c'est un écrivain très
curieux parce que il parle au fond de la
tragédie de l'histoire c'est fondamental
mais il n'en parle pas avec des trémolos
dans la voix il en parle avec humour
avec ironie et même avec plaisanterie
d'ailleurs le titre d'un de ses son
premier livre le plus fameux alors ça
c'est quand même la singularité tout à
fait extraordinaire de de kundera ce que
c est ce que vous êtes sensible à cet
aspect des choses à la fois le mélange
et de tracts le tragique avec l'ironie
la plaisanterie
oui c'est à dire c'est un propos que
vous citez vous même je sais plus c'est
dans un de vos livres dans l'un de vos
articles qu'il n'y a pas de grandes
oeuvres qu'ils ne soient aussi drôle que
la drôlerie et fait partie intégrante
des oeuvres véritablement grande
je crois que c'est la vision la dérision
et vision mais ça fait partie de la vie
de chacun ça fait partie de la vie aussi
de son pays quand il leur rappelle par
exemple à partir de jean huss de cette
noblesse tchèque qui a été massacrée
pour s'être opposée
l'empereur deviennent ensuite en 39
l'angleterre et la france qui laisse
tomber ce pays en 68 ans fait en 48 déjà
en 68 etc
il ya une espèce de de dérision
d'histoire aussi comme de dérision de
chaque vie individuelle c'est peut-être
ça la légèreté de l'être c'est qu'au
fond et c'est souhaitable même parce
qu'ils montrent aussi que l'accord avec
l'être c'est justement le régime est il
qu'il a connu si l'accord avec l'être
c'est-à-dire la pesanteur le pesanteurs
de la vie quotidienne la pesanteur des
oukases de toutes sortes etc
oui mesdames kundera ciu considère que
l'histoire avec un grand h c'est une
farce cette farce humiliante une femme
rêvée éprouvante mortels mais ce que
c'est
vous savez un romancier toujours d'un
cg1 relance est toujours très encouragés
en ce qui concerne les opinions qu'elle
exprime dans ses romans
dès le moment quand vous main quand vous
me posez la question je ne suis plus un
romancier alors j'ai jeûné
j'appelle tout d'un coup c'est de
liberté que c'est que comme mon roman
syeco comme romancier c'est à dire il
est sûr que à mes personnages l'histoire
c'est manifesterait souvent comme une
énorme présenterait ou bien que mes
personnages arrivent un certain moment
qui est très révélateur quand l'histoire
qu'ils ont pris bien sûr comme tout le
monde prend l'histoire sait rien mais ne
soyons pas un sincère l'histoire une des
rares choses que l'on emprunte je dirais
presque automatiquement au seuil
ça exige une très grande performance
intellectuelle de ne pas prendre
l'histoire
cette grande histoire de mars d
de cette histoire devant laquelle tout
le monde est à genoux cette histoire
qu'ils ne broient edena de n'est pas la
prendre au sérieux tous les goûts
propose se poser la question est ce que
tout cela n'est pas tellement bête ce
qui se passe et ce qu'il ne faut pas se
libérer
intérieurement de cette fois de
l'histoire
est-ce que c'est l'histoire qui voulait
toujours être l'incarnation de la raison
est-ce que c'est l'incarnation brito de
la pure irrationalité de la pure bêtise
d'un jeudi dans un certain dans certains
moments dans certains lieux où est placé
le personnage vous voyez le monde tout
d'un coup dans ses couleurs mais aucun
romancier digne de ce nom ne veux pas
faire des liens philosophe c'est à dire
je ne vais pas vous laisser enseigne la
philosophie de l'histoire
bon alors on va par là aussi une
constante de vos livres c'est l'érotisme
la sexualité et ce qui est tout à fait
curieux c'est que il semble que le
romancier que vous êtes ne s'intéressent
pas s'intéresse moins à l'acte charnel
couvent raconté rarement que ce qui se
passe avant ou après alors ce qui se
passe avant c'est peut être moi même la
séduction que je dirais que l'excitation
l'excitation de l'excitation et puis
après l'acte charnel vous intéresser
beaucoup à ce qui est je ne sais pas le
la séparation la mélancolie et c'est ce
que je me trompe ou non vous ne vous
trompez pas surtout dans le fait que
certains mance il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de l'érotisme dans tout
heureusement que j'ai écrit je me
rappelle même quand j'ai dit l
avant-dernière vivre livre du rire était
remplie que j'ai reçu une lettre qui m'a
fait beaucoup de plaisir d'une lectrice
qui m'a écrit pas possible et vous lire
parce que ce serment le 6 mars excellent
le sexe
j'ai pensé que j'ai enfin je vais lire
un dissident de reims
je me reposerai de sites de cette
obsession sexuelle occidental alors
rihanna bien sûr mais en même temps vous
savez les l'érotisme
aujourd'hui dans notre époque qui
caractérisé par le fait que tout et
permet vous pouvez dire jour dit
n'importe quoi sur n'importe qui
l'indiscrétion non seulement permis mais
l indice crise devenue le vertueux c'est
à dire nous dans n'importe quel livre
n'importe qui vous racontent n'importe
quel intimité n'est ce pas ça il nous
vivons dans une époque quand l'intimité
qui jadis était une valeur n'est plus
une valve on dévalorise complètement
l'intimité c'est à dire qu'est ce que
c'est la personnalité humaine sans
intimité sans sa vie privée au moment
car la vie privée n'est plus la vie
privée la personnalité humaine c'est
évapore alors nous vivons un peu ce
moment là donc cette grande invasion de
la sexualité de l'érotisme dans la
littérature
je dois dire que je suis j'ai quelques
réserves
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui m'a qui
m'enchante
kiki qui m'a qui m'enchante sens sans
aucune réserve malgré cette année malgré
malgré cela je suis bien sûr très attiré
par les situations érotiques mais
seulement dans la mesure où cette
situation érotique mais dit quelque
chose en plus
seul est donc seulement dans la mesure
où cette situation érotique est
révélatrice si tout d'un coup vous avez
dit que l'acte charnel n'est pas si
souvent traités dans mes livres c'est
pas tout à fait vrai je crois qu'on ne
peut même faire toute une anthologie des
coïts très intéressant qui sont là bas
mais seco et ses actes d'amour sont
toujours une révélation inattendue ou
bien d'une situation par exemple de
rapport des forces entre la femme et
l'homme ou bien des caractères de deux
personnages par exemple dans le dernier
roman il y à un acte d'amour entre la
personne de personnes sabina et surtout
d'un coup sabine à leur égard n'est ce
pas en faisant l'amour avec lui et j'ai
l'impression de cette grande pompe plein
de muscles sans fin de compte un immense
chiot petit chien keith hallett parce
que 7 septembre qui a sept as et
d'attitude des ongles féministe à
l'égard de la femme citoyenne adorateurs
de la femme même adam dans l'acte
d'amour un caractère tellement nous
viril que tout d'un coup recettes sabina
d'emblée dans un moment de deuil de
d'éclairage sur le site comprend que
c'est pas possible
maurice nadeau comme ça oui mais
quelquefois j'aimerais qu'on vous
résumer un petit peu le livre il n'est
pas raisonnable lire le dernier
l'insoutenable légèreté oui parce qu'il
ferait bon qu'est-ce que caisse comme ça
en quelques fois comment le présenter
aïe difficile
oui parce que
parce qu'on l'a dit tout à l'heure enfin
ses effets de variations à la fois sur
l'histoire de personnages quand même
principe quand même deux personnages
principaux un seul chien 4084 m'appelle
il ya deux pour nous qui sont peut-être
mais je comprends que vous les métiers
de tous sur le même plan si c'est vrai
c'est vrai oui d'autant plus que sabina
n'est pas un personnage fait dire qu'il
y en a qui s'appelle thomas qui donne la
chirurgie au chien de prague qui va en
consultation dans une petite ville de
bohème qui la bat rencontre en tuant le
temps à la lettre dans une brasserie une
serveuse s'appelle tandis qu'ils
s'appellent teresa pendant que la radio
joue le quatuor de beethoven deux
derniers parce que lens est important
c'est important passé le motif qui va
revenir bien sûr dans le livre et elle
se prend de sympathie pour lui elles
l'accompagnent à la gare et il lui dit
ciao la prochaine et c'est bon parce que
c'est un celi leader il faut dire que
c'est un séducteur
non mais c'est pas seulement la raison
c'est qu'il a un livre ouvert sur la
table est en train de lire
et cette fille a toujours eu beaucoup de
respect pour les gens qui avaient des
livres de même que l'histoire de
beethoven salle l'intéressent parce que
là était un concert après il était petit
peu de gens c'était un peu enfin il ya
la musique à toutes sortes de hasard
l'importance du hasard c'est aussi ça
c'est bien parce qu'un livre sur le
hasard oui oui mais bien puisqu'il en
fait compte d'ailleurs
oui on va pas rajouter de l'histoire
mais simplement il faut dire donc c'est
un couple et que lui qui ne se liège a
mais avec aucune femme sauf qui s'est
marié une première fois mais voilà il se
méfier des femmes celui des femmes et
finalement il va l'épouser et au fond ne
sais pas trop pourquoi
et puis ensuite cette femme au fond il
ya l'invasion de la tchécoslovaquie par
les troupes soviétiques
ils vont tous les deux ans en suisse
mais finalement elle revient est lui
toujours aussi guidé par une sait trop
quoi il revient et au fonds pour leur
malheur à tous les deux puisque et il ne
voulant pas être bien noté par le régime
ne voulant pas
être renier les idées qu'il avait pu
professé a vendu du temps du printemps
de prague et bien il va devenir laveur
de carreaux et puis chauffeur de camion
et c'est ainsi qu'il trouvera un jour là
meurent alors il ya deux autres
personnages effectivement il ya une
autre personnage qui est beaucoup plus
libre c'est la sabine à ses maîtresses
et c'est une de ses maîtresses et puis
un autre clic et français france
justement je suis et qui est actuel
intellectuel occidental etc voilà alors
qu'est-ce que sur ces variations donc à
la fois politique erratique et le regard
jetez-vous aussi monde est ce vraiment
où il ya une chose dont j'ai horreur et
sont les gens qui parlent sans être
compétent pour je ne suis pas critique
littéraire et j'ai encore une fois j'ai
l'impression que si je me mettais à
pontifier sont l'oeuvre de kundera que
j'ai immensément jeu je déplorais je
voulais pas parler je préfère avant son
décès alors non mais vous voulez même
pas donner votre sentiment
mon sentiment est un sentiment
d'admiration
mais je pense qu'il est très peu utile
et au contraire il est même encombrant
lorsque vous êtes devant une oeuvre de
beauté dire comme c'est beau très bien
alors bon ce qui est intéressant il ya
beaucoup de choses et bien passionnant
dans votre lit thomas ce qui refuse
quand ils rentrent en tchécoslovaquie
il refuse d'être bien noté s'est dit
plusieurs fois parce que évidemment on
note tout le monde surveille tout le
monde est ce que ce n'est pas ce qui
vous est arrivé vous il ya le refus
aussi d'être bien noté
papa tu pas tout à fait non ma situation
était un peu différent
c'est très bien l'autobus
non je vous lis dans cette situation
quand les russes on veut ni pinson et
voulait même pas vous ne demandez pas
même des mois une collaboration s'est
tarie j'étais dans ce sens là dans une
situation moralement très facile
beaucoup plus facile que par exemple
sept romans qui quand même était avait
un certain possibilité de démission a
besoin ce chirurgien
on a besoin de chirurgie besoin de faire
pas seulement besoin et même une passion
intérieur qui est tout à fait légitime
c'est-à-dire la situation pour ces gens
étaient vraiment vraiment d'une
difficile d'une difficulté
extraordinaire ils sont toujours en vie
du il faut dire ces personnages façon
c'est jamais du blanc et du noir comme
une situation c'est que quand il revient
à prague
bah il n'est ni permis de l'est ce qu'on
appellera les résistants ni parmi ceux
qu'on appellera les collaborationnistes
en feuillet on lui dit ah tu as
autrefois écrit un article
et tu vas le faire ton auto critique il
refuse mais en même temps cet article
c'était pas vraiment lui puisqu'on avait
coupé c'était très beau d'ailleurs
c'était sur le sur le mini ddip veille
il avait communiste disant savais pas
ben ils disent non plus avait pas
seulement quand on lui a appris
il s'est crevé les yeux bon est bon il
n'a pas écrit exactement fonds lui a
coupé cet article mais on veut lui faire
maintenant renier
de l'autre côté on veut lui faire avouer
cet article identique eu envie lui sait
pas trop quoi faire
heureusement le régime connaît ses vrais
ennemis et le dégradent rétrograde plus
tôt et de d'hôpital en dispensaire puis
finalement offert la veille à carreaux
muse mais l'amour de de theresa et
thomas c'est aussi pas une chose simple
oui mais rien n'est simple avec une non
non c'est toujours il ya toujours un
refus du sentimentalisme aussi
absolument jamais sauf un moment parce
qu'il ya un chien qui s'appelle karénine
et il ya des pages assume admirable sur
la mort de ce chien cette mort préfigure
d'ailleurs là la mort des deux
personnages thomas et teresa est ce que
là vous ne vous laissez pas aller vous
aussi kundera au sentimentalisme
j'espère que non à j'espère qu'un an de
ce bien sûr c'est pas à moi de juger
c'est je trouve le roman réussi c'est à
dire je trouve que je n'ai pas tomber
dans ce piège mais vous avez tout à fait
raison que ce piège existait et que
c'était quelque chose très risqué je
savais que après après la partie si ce
qui est très cynique qui est très brutal
qui est sarcastique
tout d'un coup se sentent est là
la nécessité finir dans un dans un bento
adagio très très lente et dans une
atmosphère disons idyllique mais cette
idée est mineure est minée par la mort
qui va venir
n'est ce pas c'est à dire même s'est dit
il est terriblement ambiguë elle est
tellement en belgique je ne crois pas
que c'est un sentiment tableau est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
formule 2 de claude roy dans le mail
observateurs qui rendant compte de votre
livre dit ceci il s'agit au fond ce
livre d'un jeu résume évidemment mais il
emploie cette formule je trouve pour ma
part assez vrai c'est l'amour sans joie
et l'histoire sans espoir l'histoire
sans espoir 1 histoire sans espoir et
l'amour sans joie je voudrais qu'il y
beaucoup de joie entre entre vos deux
ans deux amants d'abord et ensuite mari
et femme vous savez ce que c'est sûr que
chaque mouvement pourrait avoir
plusieurs lectures et plus étant donné
que les personnages sont j'espère très
complexe très ambigu c'est a dit même
les rames ou vous pouvez la considérer
ou bien d'une prise et elle phase de
reprise est repoussée par exemple si
jamais je devais donner un seul mot pour
résumer votre livre ce qui a peu absurde
mais enfin pourquoi pas c'est un jeu je
gens pourraient le mot occupation parce
que je trouve que c'est un roman de
l'occupation d'un pays par un
envahisseur
c'est le roman de l'occupation des
esprits par par une occupation d esprit
oui par des apparatchiks par des
collaborateurs et c'est l'occupation des
corps des corps de femmes par un don
juan
voilà un peu le mot qui moi moi mais je
sais très bien tout le monde pour un
proposer d'autres et c'est vrai que
c'est ça qui est intéressant dans vos
livres c'est que au fond ne s'est pas
trop ya bien marqué j'ai lu les articles
sur votre lit les critiques sont un peu
embarrassé pour en rendre compte à ne
savent pas trop par quel bout tirez vous
êtes un il ya trop de boue oui je sais
pas non mais c'est je pense que oui je
crois qu'il a voulu faire le roman de la
totalité enfin si mais on ne peut rien
il admire hermann broch enfin on y
trouve des on y trouve quelque chose une
influence des somnambules enfin de cette
différence de ton de variations dans vie
de d'intégrer l'histoire avec un grand h
aux histoires des individus bon alors on
va parler maintenant de à moi que vous
lui ajouter autre chose on va parler de
réparer d'orwell alors avec le livre de
simon leys orwell où l'horreur de la
politique qui je lis un petit livre mais
à mon avis il était patent pour comme
introduction à la vie et à l'oeuvre
de george orwell et je pense quand on a
lu ce livre on a envie de lire ou de
relire évidemment 1984 et la ferme des
animaux qui sont les plus connus
d'orwell mais aussi beaucoup d'autres
livres qui sont très peu connu des
français et nous verrons qui sont
disponibles cependant alors j'ai j'ai
envie de dire que j'ai envie de vous
dire tout de suite un petit peu ça donne
le ton de votre livre le les premières
lignes on a peine à croire qu'il ya déjà
34 encore welder dans son petit
cimetière campagnard summer continue à
nous parler avec plus de force et de
clarté que la plupart des commentateurs
et politiciens dont nous pouvons lire la
prose dans le journal de ce matin
alors on voit le ton du livre mais
rappelons tout de suite sur orwell c'est
que effectivement il est mort en 1952 la
tuberculose et qu'il a écrit ces deux
livres majeurs alors dit 1984 en quelle
année
juste avant de juste avant de nous est
apparu quelques mois comme en avant et
la ferme des animaux 45 45
la ferme des animaux écrite un peu plus
tôt il a dû attendre un an et demi pour
pouvoir la publier la censure en
angleterre à ce moment-là interdisait de
publier un livre qui était défavorable
pour le grand allié soviétique
bon alors ce qui est curieux dans les
quelques pages vous consacré à la vie
d'orwell c'est que au fond il a
découvert la misère l'injustice assez
tard dans sa vie et on peut dire que
cette découverte l'a complètement
chamboulé transformé ça modifie le cours
de sa vie oui c'est vrai c'est une loi
presque le hasard d'une enquête
en milieu ouvrier au moment de la
dépression dans le nord industriel de
l'angleterre qui lui a fait rencontrer
donc cette misère ouvriers et qui a été
le point de départ de ce qu'ils étaient
on pourrait dire sa conversion au
socialisme leur part le mot conversion
le mucha interreligieux parce que son
essence est pas une adhésion un
mouvement politique c'est beaucoup plus
une adhésion à un ensemble de valeurs de
valeurs morales vous parlez de
l'honnêteté massive d'orwell
qu'appelez-vous l'honnêteté massive le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas d'intervalle ou
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de comment
dire qui est une unité entre ce qu'il
écrit est ce qu'il est oui parce qu'il
faut bien dire construire n'est pas un
homme de lettres ce point de vue c'est
ça vous êtes un homme et qui écrit c'est
le contraire fondez vous dit même que
alors on peut s'en moquer un peu mais
effectivement quand il découvre la
misère et bien le dis je le vivent la
misère avec les miséreux alors il
devient un clochard à paris d'ailleurs à
londres etc et mais c'est une expérience
fausses oui ça reste une expérience
artificielle à beaucoup d'égards parce
que il peut en sortir à tout moment et
qu'en fait il l'est toujours un
spectateur même quand il vit la misère
avec les miséreux il reste quand même un
membre de l'élite anglaise qui a eu une
autre éducation qui a eu un autre qui a
accès à d'autres valeurs culturelles etc
honnêteté massive au site simon les deux
patrons de george orwell est bien et il
s'engage dans la guerre d'espagne
il va aux côtés des républicains lutter
contre contre le fascisme et ça c'est
très important aussi dans sa vie
ce set décisif dans sa vie comme il le
dit lui-même
ce qui est assez étonnant parce que bien
avant d'aller en espagne je l'avais déjà
parler de sa foi dans le socialisme
en fait ce n'est qu'après son passage de
la guerre d'espagne qui dit maintenant
en fait je crois au socialisme il ya eu
un bref interlude pendant un bref
épisode au moment où est arrivé à
barcelone il ya eu le sentiment que la
révolution était possible que la
fatalité révolutionnaire était possible
etait-ce une illusion ou pas c'est une
autre c'est une autre question
mais dans l'histoire de sa vie ça a été
un moment décisif
le ce moment où il ne devrait plus jouer
la comédie pour se faire passer pour un
prolétaire
simplement il était volontaire est
accepté comme un camarade parmi d'autres
on s'interrogeait plus sur le fait qu'il
avait l'accent a des bonnes écoles et le
il était simplement camarades offrons
lui tant dans la même lutte pour la
première fois il a réalisé la
possibilité d'une fraternité effective
et réelle avec comme les déshérités que
ce socialiste qui restait socialiste
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours écrivent de
livres qui sont donc la ferme des
animaux surtout le plus connu 1984 qui
sont justement deux machines de guerre
formidable contre le socialiste parce
que simultanément avec cette découverte
la possibilité d'une révolution de la
possibilité d'un socialisme et découvre
en même temps la réalité du
totalitarisme c'est le la répression les
staliniens qui s'efforcent des lignes
qui sont bien plus préoccupés d'éliminer
les milices anarchiste que de lutter
contre les fascistes et qui exerce une
censure stricte sur ce qui se passe
réellement au fond d'espagne c'est la
réalité
donc cette réalité meurtrière
de la bête et totalitaire à laquelle il
est confronté
ce qui fait que sa découverte est double
d'un côté il ya la possibilité une
révolution à socialisme d'un autre côté
cette révolution n'est possible que si
simultanément on dénonce le
totalitarisme soviétique
l'avènement du socialisme ne pourra se
faire que après qu'on ait exposé et
dénoncé la alors de le mans sont deux
autres questions pourquoi l'horreur de
la politique orwell où l'horreur de
l'appel de la politique c'est une
citation andorre où elle lui même louis
10 depuis la guerre d'espagne et depuis
ce que j'ai vu ensuite des mécanismes
politiques à l'intérieur des partis de
gauche
j'ai acquis l'horreur de la politique
est évidemment vous placer très haut
1984 et surtout la ferme des animaux
dites vous la ferme des animaux étaient
aux dents voile lui-même c'est la seule
de ses oeuvres qu'ils étaient satisfaits
c'est la seule de ses oeuvres qu'il
estimait réussi sur un plan esthétique
il faut dire en deux mots ce que c'est
que la ferme des animaux parce que je
croyais pas beaucoup de français qui
l'ont lu des frontonnais non sens que je
veux c'est vrai qu'il peut vous pensez
bien qu'on ne puisse se trouver dans
livre de poche alors en deux mots sont
dans une ferme sont les animaux qui
prennent qui se révoltent contre les
hommes et qui d'un seul coup se mettent
à gérer la ferme d'abord dans la jirs
est dans la démocratie
et puis et puis se forment une nouvelle
élite qui confisque cette révolution la
ferme des animaux en fait une méditation
sur sur l'impossibilité de la révolution
bon alors milan kundera est ce que vous
aimez orwell pour être tout à fait fin
non non pourquoi mais si je suis sincère
je sais que je sais en même temps
terriblement injuste alors je tombais
dans ses dix ans dans ce piège de la
sincérité peut-être j'ai fait une bêtise
le tout simplement tous les to les
déranger une telle aversion à l'égard de
la littérature politique à la thèse
didactique qui nous donne des leçons qui
n'est pas qui est plutôt une
illustration des thèses que depuis
toujours j'avais une allergie à priori
qu contrôler ces d'allergies et et un
juge
parce que plus tard quand j'ai connu au
revers l'auteur des essais quand je
savais un peu plus d'an lui alors j'ai
j'ai commencé à apprécier ça
extraordinaire lucidité qui qu'on peut
voir même dans les romans que je n'aime
pas beaucoup comme demain ensuite quand
je sais pas c'est parce que j'avais à
l'égard de revel une attitude très
compliqué une attitude où je n'étais
absolument pas sûr de moi je n'ai aucune
certitude que mon jugement est vrai
alors avec d'autres en plus grande
curiosité j'ai lu ligonnès qui est
magnifique mais il passe quelques très
courts ce 150 pages extrêmement dense et
aurait expliqué à la barre avec une
brièveté avec une condensation avec
exactitude réforme dont l'exactitude est
vraiment belle et même j'ai commencé à
aimer au revers même avec ses faiblesses
si mauvaise à cause de six mois et
peut-être à cause de leurs huîtres qui
est wiki refedd aimé parce que tout d'un
coup jamais
naughty voit alors se dotèrent que tu
n'aimes pas par espace diderot politique
en fin de concert par l'horaire de la
politique qu'il a détesté ces régimes
totalitaires qui sont en fin de compte
la la politisation totale de tous et par
l'honneur de la politique il se j'étais
content de ces régimes passera par la
façon la plus directe et la plus
efficace c'est-à-dire la crise
un roman politique mais ils ne répondent
pas à tourner esthétique mais mais la
masse des rares il n'y a pas de me
défiance vis-à-vis d'orwell une raison
que sur laquelle insiste simon leys à
savoir que orwell a été récupéré par ce
qu'on appelle la nouvelle droite qui en
a fait un de ces écrivains favoris il
n'y a pas c'est un nom c'est très
intéressant ici dans les délais mais le
fait que je suis est récupérée n'ai pas
récupéré ça m'est complètement égal
je ne crois pas que c'est quelqu'un sait
récupérer mais où va bien je peux être
équilibré par n'importe qui et c'est
toujours moi ça ne m'intéresse vraiment
pas et c'était allergies que j'avais
encore à prendre parce que vous savez là
quand vous êtes entourés par la
politisation des tours où la littérature
n'est plus littérature ou la littérature
doit toujours servir à quelque chose
alors vous commencé à détester même la
littérature qui sert aux idées tout à
fait justes et l'omb tout simplement
vous détestez voir la littérature série
vous voit vous voulez voir la
littérature autonome mais est-ce que
vous êtes sensibles quand même aux
prophéties assez extraordinaire 1990
c'est pourquoi je dise cette sincérité
pour être enfin pu confondre les choses
or vers une personnalité extraordinaire
un intellectuel extraordinaire penseurs
extrême
qui a vu des jeunes espoirs pendant la
guerre d'espagne la guerre de lesparre
qui portent ou l'intelligentia et
l'image d'épinal américain alors bien
d'autres livres d'ailleurs qu'on peut
trouver sur la guerre d'espagne ce qui
est l'un des trois livres majeurs j'ai
cité la femme qui s'ingèrent hommage à
la catalogne qui est aussi disponible en
france aux éditions champ vivre qui
publie aussi d'autres ouvrages de six
mois mais y avait je vous cite là c'est
une phrase extraite de la soutenable
légèreté de l'être
on a l'impression que vous racontez le
livre la ferme des animaux les régimes
criminels n'ont pas été façonné par des
criminels mais par des enthousiastes
convaincu d'avoir découvert l'unique
voie du paradis et il défend des vagues
amant seppois exécutants pour cela
beaucoup de monde
plus tard il devint clair comme le jour
que le pari que le paradis n'existait
pas et que les enthousiastes étaient
donc des assassins c'est la ferme des
animaux ça c'est tout à fait ça alors
maurice nadeau
qu'est-ce que quel est votre regard sur
moi je trouve que c'est un homme
admirable orwell et dès que j'ai lu la
ferme des animaux s'étaient c'était dans
une petite édition parce qu'il a trouvé
difficilement l'éditeur même pour les
français en 45 chez madame odile pâte et
j'ai encore cette édition là et j'ai lu
après l'hommage à la catalogne et c'est
ça qui m'a fait non j'oublie tout
c'est la vache enragée que j'ai bu avant
la guerre que j'ai eue avant la guerre
que j'ai trouvé chez un bouquiniste et
avec une préface de panne et istrati et
c'est ptet la vie d'un plongeur de
restaurant bon etc
c'était la mode à l'époque de la
littérature prolétarienne enfin en paix
lui est allé aussi au peuple comme guy
simon leys tout à l'heure mais c'est un
homme donne c'est un homme qui n'était
pas doué je crois pour l'écriture et
c'est ça qui est admirable chez lui
c'est sa ténacité son courage son
courage physique aussi puisqu'il est
allé en catalogne dabaya vais tout de
même pas foule et son courage aussi
politique
parce qu'à ce moment là il a été un des
rares
enfin à dire mais les staliniens sont en
train sont des contre-révolutionnaires
ils sont en train de mettre cette
révolution par terre on ne le croyait
pas enfin qu'ils étaient ceux qui à
l'époque le croyait il ya qu'à lire
l'espoir de malraux il ya deux cas lire
beaucoup en fait toute la presse de
gauche
la presse de gauche et n est ce pas la
guerre d'abord la révolution ensuite lui
avait la position des anarchistes et des
poux mist la révolution d'abord la
garantie ou plutôt la révolution
permettra de gagner la guerre contre
franco c'est pas fini de l'une et
l'autre des hypothèses ne s'est vérifiée
et sans ses deux livres au fond la vache
enragée l hommage à la catalogne que je
préfère aux deux autres qui sont un peu
devenu un peu la tarte à la crème oui
mais est-ce que ça ça m'a dit de 54 et
d'actrice et une réaction de télé le
parisien passait presque 1984 devenu un
best-seller alors on aime moins
le collège esthétique on le trouvera
dans la vache enragée que dans enfin dit
mais est ce qu'on le trouve en france la
vache enragée
c'était publié chez gallimard champ
libre à des chats paris a baissé ça
parce que je connaissais pas son
originale sélection sa meilleure édition
dans la dèche la partie allait bien on
en trouve un volume 6o ans trouve la
pendaison puis un éléphant et y attirer
quelques noms mais pour en revenir à ça
un type comme ça que ce côté puritains
peu et aristocrates si vous voulez enfin
il stockera tu de moyenne classe comme
ils disent là-bas enfin je ne sais plus
qui a le courage aussi laissez pas
simplement pour ce quel courage de vivre
une vie de clochard ou d'aller même en
tant que journaliste faire une
faire un reportage chez les mineurs du
nord de l'angleterre
c'est un supérieur qui pouvait
absolument pas plaire à 1000 r qu'il a
connu au mip à la même époque et
catherine millet tanak ou comment se
fait-il que ces deux hommes qui étaient
aux antipodes l'un de l'autre se sont
estimés et que 1000 r lui a dit bon
quand on ne traduit pas pour l'espagnol
le pauvre imbécile vous n'avez pas assez
souffert comme ça
maintenant quand même il lui a donné une
veste de velours pour le protéger du
froid quoi vous le raconter aussi honey
et bien moi l'estiment de miller pour
orwell est aussi c'est un exemple si un
peu pour moi de deux personnes qui sont
antinomiques et qui s'estime alors
maintenant kafka évidemment c'est votre
compatriote bien entendu et là vous
l'aimez beaucoup ça on le sait ça va de
soi mais vous n'êtes pas un peu au début
dé des snobs et j'ai vu quelques clark
vous plaignez de 2 à ce que vous appelez
la caf cologie alors qu'est-ce que quels
sont les bêtises qu'on colporte sur
kafka et et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire de kafka quand on
s'appelle coup de mer a rapidement bien
entendu c'est vrai ça pourquoi
c'est pourtant un déficit d'un point
pour les français un français
aujourd'hui pourquoi de thil lire kafka
voilà je pose ma question autrement
un français aujourd'hui un jeune
français il a il a 15 ans et la saison
il a 18 ans elle a 20 ans et bien qu est
ce qu il faut qu ils lisent de kafka et
pourquoi l'at-il de dire qu'ils lisent
sur tous
les deux romans les plus célèbres c'est
à dire le château le procès du crack up
cela ou presque est le plus grand ce qui
m'a inscrit main ce qui m'attriste dans
dans le destin des caf quand même je ne
me trompais pas ce qu'on tourne très
facilement dans dans les illusions
surtout quand on polémique n'est ce pas
quelque chose vous les mecs que je tout
d'un coup comment ça exagéré mais j'ai
l'impression que kafka est aujourd'hui
en deuil un des auteurs les plus
célèbres d'un peu d'aidé le plus
absolument le monstre de la célébrité et
de l'autre côté de cette un hôtel qui
n'est pas vraiment et sincèrement m
je soupçonne le public cultivé je ne
parle pas des spécialistes mais ce
public cultivé qui aiment savoir vélo et
abda et flaubert cetera je ne crois pas
qu'ils aiment vraiment kafka je crois
qu'après un peu qu'ils ont un peu peur
de kafka requête m en k-1 renommée des
notaires terriblement difficile les
autres que les gens le lisent avec un
trac
un peu comme le faisait un test de
l'intelligence pour me faisais un examen
elles se disent est ce que je serai
suffisamment intelligents pour
comprendre ces de terre tellement
incompréhensible et ainsi je crois que
c'était de la chose fondamentale
fondamental pour rire regard c'est à
dire le plaisir
la fascination on ne lit kafka sans être
fasciné fasciné parcours personnel et
sauna d'après mon avis et dans son
imagination
parce que kafka apporter comme tout à
fait nouveau ce qui n'existait pas avant
c'est une autre imagination imagination
qui ressemble à l'imagination des rêves
l'imagination qui vous qui vous conduit
dans un univers où se passe des choses
qui ne sont pas vrais samba
jusqu'à kafka la vraisemblance était
plus la condition du roman ne pouvait
même pas imaginer un roman qui serait
invraisemblable tandis que tout d'un
coup ils libèrent la fantasy il crée une
univers où leurs effets mais à la
réalité et cette imagination à quelque
chose
extraordinairement beau et fascinant
manque cela on manque l'essentiel et on
ne lit plus kafka commun comme un
artiste
ce n'est plus une oeuvre d'art mais
c'est quelque chose à déchiffrer
simon leys à la fin d'ailleurs de votre
livre il ya quelques lignes je demande
comparaison entre orwell kafka parce que
il est vrai qu'on les a souvent
rapprochés l'un de l'autre et que ce
n'est pas une comparaison catastrophe
catastrophique mais pourtant ce trafic
pour juste mais qui peut-on comparer ce
cas c'est un c'est un artiste tellement
et pourtant vous faites la comparaison
c'est ça vous l'a dénoncée en même temps
vous faites vous dites en trois lignes
et quelle est la différence entre ol et
kafka vous rappelez oui alors allez-y
mais que la condition la condition
humaine vivre une situation kafkaïenne
et vivre avant l'univers totalité une
condition était une situation
orwellienne on voit le s'adresse à un
problème spécifique et particulier le
problème du totalitarisme qui est le
problème politique de notre époque et de
ce point de vue là oh well as une
urgence immédiate pour nous maintenant
mais peut-être pas une très grande
permanence enfin j'espère qu'il sera
démené et dans 20 ans tandis que je
n'imagine pas comment carca pourrait
jamais être démodé tant qu'il y aura des
êtres humains
oui qui expliquez-moi pourquoi kafka par
rapport à l'univers totalitaire et
l'autre alors ils dénoncent quoi
quelqu'un kafka ne dénonce rien mais il
nous explique notre propre existence
notre difficulté à vivre il me semble
aussi et sans oublier encore une fois
cette dimension ses dimensions d'humour
ses dimensions de drôlerie le tragique
kafkaïenne je crois
l'été le leitmotiv des snobs justement
qui ont oublié le point de départ de
kaka qui est quand même extraordinaire
drôlerie oui ce qu'il a joué mais
d'avoir le point de vue de ceux qu on a
beaucoup critiqué les traductions de
d'alexandre qu alexandre vialatte avait
fait de kafka
mais je me demande si malgré toutes les
fautes qui peuvent avoir fait en
allemand etc
c'est le grand mérite de vialatte n'est
pas justement d'avoir perçu cette
drôlerie incongru de quartier donc vous
voyez alors je viens des cousinages plus
que frappant entre kundera et kafka
vesoul a aussi ça paraît évident oui ça
paraît évident ça paraît évident oui là
la comparaison
oui evra père tandis qu'a fait caen où
elle évidemment on est à un niveau
esthétiquement inférieur orwell n'est
pas un très grand artiste en moins
d'être un très grand homme est un très
grand esprit est un guide d'un guide
dont nous avons besoin pour tâcher de
comprendre le monde dans lequel nous
vivons
les réalités politiques auxquels nous
sommes confrontés mais ce n'est pas un
artiste de première importance et
maurice nadeau alors que bien ce qui est
bien avec kafka si ce qui est bien avec
tous les grands écrivains c'est que
chacun a le sien à chacun a eu c'est
l'argent des comptes et une quantité il
ya le kafka théologien il ya le caf cape
town me disent tu y ailles kafka à
partir d' absurde solide camus yole
kafka existentialiste celui de sarp il
ya le kafka structuraliste heuliez 4cad
lacanien tout le monde a son kafka somme
c'est excellent mais ça prouve que
ça prouve que quand même en effet il
dépasse de beaucoup je dis pas notre
entendement comme comme vous dites c'est
pas un auteur difficile si vous voulez
il dit il dit ce qu'il faut dire il le
dit d'une façon précise et dur
comment dire c'est une façon d'écrire
aussi qu'il a qui était très différente
en facilite aussi par là qui nous a qui
nous a séduit enfin quand on pense à son
époque l'expressionnisme allemand au
pathétisme et c'est cet homme qui dit
qui paraît être un écrivain réaliste
avec le côté fantastique c'était tout à
fait tout à fait étonnant bah oui et et
après ça est ce que vous voyez une
filiation donc entre les la kings à
l'oeil à le coller sous tchèque et même
bien sûr c'est la dérision c'est le
comique se sont il n'y a pas de
psychologie pas plus chez lui que chez
kafka
enfin c'est la métaphysique peut-être
mais pas de psychologie
ça ne les intéresse pas mis l'un ni
l'autre ce sont les individus sont je
dirais pas des pantins mais enfin ce
sont des sondés fruit du hasard et des
circonstances et bondues tempérament
aussi
enfin il ya cette ya de grandes lois qui
les mène alors question absurde mais
vous pensez aussi que kafka aurait
devant orwell la même le même sentiment
que
que kundera est au fond il parce qu'une
parce qu'on voit elle n'est pas à ses
artistes
il n'aimerait pas le seuil difficile
dédié je ne sais pas non je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas parce que mon allergie
est très injuste et kafka était par
contre le nom extrêmement juste beaucoup
plus juste que moi et puis mon allergie
et echoes est historiquement parce que
je vous ai dit dans certaines cours de
ma vie autour de moi l'art était
seulement la propagande et tout d'un
coup il y avait quelque chose qui a pour
moi avait aussi le caractère d'une anti
pro parra c'est à dire j'étais dans
damages injustices à l'égard du revers
très historiquement conditionné ce qui
ne pouvait pas être le cas de kafka
si on imagine la situation que kafka
lieu révèlent alors je ne crois pas
qu'il serait méchant là-dedans
qu'est-ce que vous recommander aussi aux
jeunes gens qui vous le découvrir kafka
vous recommander aussi les deux livres
un petit texte ou les deux bien sûr le
château et la colonie pénitentiaire
colonie pénitentiaire aussi et vous
simon leys mais je recommanderais je
trouve pour aborder l'oeuvre de kafka
à mon sens plus de laisser que j'ai
jamais lu sur kaka la vitesse et de
philip roth deux parties l'une théorique
et l'autre les choses s'il n'est pas
trahi au conseil
en ce qui concerne philip roth a encore
un passage magnifique sur kafka dans son
roman qui s'appelle le professeur du
professeur de désir il ya un passage
comme professeur américain vient après
recherches sur les traces de kafka et
c'est 7,7 à merveille des merveilles sur
le caf
j'ai dit mary d'introduction à propos de
prague
vous avez publié vous publiez c'est
souvent des études des articles dans le
la revue le débat en actifs fixes hors
dia le titre est frappant c'est prague
poèmes qui disparaît qu'est-ce que
pendant trois mots que pouvez-nous dire
prague prime qui disparaît c'est un
article à la fois plein de joie de
nostalgie un peu de colère aussi
non parce que prague était une de syrte
où d'un autre siècle une des grands
centres culturels européens à côté de
vienne
c'était un des plus grands centres
urbains de la culture est ce que je vous
dis que ce sont les banalités non tout
le monde le sait après 40 45 7 grands
centres de la culture occidentale
parce qu'on oublie que ce pays est tous
ces pays comme à paul nizon rêviez pays
occidentaux
ces pays occidentaux ne sont tout d'un
coup plus les pays occidentaux ils sont
culturellement colonisés mais d'une
façon extrêmement brutale là à la fois
lente patiente est brutal et sont
colonisés à la culture est effacé
c'est un aspect qui échappe un peu parce
qu'on voit toujours cette situation ce
manque dans la terminologie purement
politique
mais l'aspect culturel échappe ce qui
échappe c'est que cette cette grande
culture et gommer de la carte de
l'europe se sont eux aussi une question
un peu on espère la question d'elle de
la langue
quand on parle par exemple de démocratie
populaire de l'est se sont trop un
mensonge dans une seule phrase parce
qu'ils ne sont ni démocratie ni
populaire ni d'ethnie deux res mais ce
n'est pas seulement ip d'un intérim ça
ça change tout parce que si vous dites
ce sont les pays des rêves alors tout
est en ordre
c'est tout à fait un autre si les pays
de l'est on en laisse c'est tout à fait
un autre si les pays de l'est appartient
à le grand empire de l'est mais ce ne
sont pas les pays de l'est
alors vous voyez avec un mauvais
vocabulaire et c'est la pensée très
orwélienne avec le mauvais vocabulaire
on et pep a développé une bonne pensée
on est perdu et que tout notre travail
devrait être là la vérification de
chaque mort en fin de compte le des voix
de l'écrivain de veiller sur la pureté
de chaque bon et dernière question
ce jeudi s'il me disait il ya quelques
mois que son plus grand désir
ce serait un jour de rentrée en russie
et peut-être d'y finir sa vie est-ce que
vous votre plus grand désir ce sera un
jour de rentrée à prague
mon plus grand désir et déconnecte de
mes amis à la france merci alors je
terminais auriez pas mal de livres a
montré alors à côté du livre de pays
simon leys il ya un livre qui est tout à
fait extraordinaire qui est une
biographie de george orwell qui était
faite par un britannique s'appelle
bernard creek qui publie aux éditions
balland il faut dire que simon leys que
orwell ne voulait pas qu'on écrive un
seul par testament il pas écrire ma
biographie
enfin on l'a fait quand même c'est
fondamental
la biographie définissent et ça passait
l'assemblée pour moi c'est un très bon
livre alors bon évidemment 1984 d'y
aller très vite et on a dû vous le
montrez d'ailleurs pendant qu'on parlait
aux éditions gallimard
je montre aussi l'enjeu parlait donc de
la d'orwell la ferme des animaux on peut
le trouver donc en livre de poche tout
orwell où la route 1984 chez robert
laffont de jean daniel gerber n 16 sont
des essais 1985 par gurry d'allos alors
c'est un hongrois qui d'une manière très
humoristique raconte la suite d'orwell
éditions la découverte maspero le 1984
c'est publié c'est une réflexion
évidemment sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le monde par l'abe le
genre humain
c'est une neuvième livraison avec
beaucoup d'auteurs 1984 sous le règne de
l'ambivalence une relecture d'orwell par
françois bruneau édition des lettres
modernes
alors évidemment le orwell ça pleut tous
les côtés spécial orwell 1984 les années
30 c'est publié par l'université de
nantes
le vingtième siècle revue d'histoire le
premier est évidemment là aussi s'est
consacré à orwell la revue esprit de son
numéro de janvier publiées à côté
beaucoup d'autres textes bien entendu
des études sur orwell et avec trois
inédits d'orwell je crois que cela vous
intéressera le magazine littéraire a
publié un numéro spécial sur george
orwell
et puis alors kundera on vous a montré
ses livres dans la collection blanche de
gallimard mais vous pouvez aussi vous
procurer ces ouvrages dans la collection
de poche folio
voici alors maintenant je passe à kafka
elle y en a beaucoup
alors le le procès vous avez le choix
pour le procès vous avez trois
traductions livre de poche vous avez
d'abord folio la traduction d'alexandre
vialatte qui est qui date d'il ya très
longtemps
il y a alors chez collection ça ces
presses pocket la nouvelle une nouvelle
traduction qui est dû à jorge ait eu
george arthur goldschmidt et puis enfin
cascade dans la collection gf flammarion
vous avez une nouvelle traduction qui
est dû à bernard lortholary voilà alors
bien entendu de kafka et bien voilà le
château la muraille de chine l'amérique
la colonie pénitentiaire dont vous avez
parlé vous avait recommandé maurice
nadeau
il y a aussi le journal de de kafka qui
n'est pas du tout une intéressante bien
au contraire
là les préparatifs de noces à la
campagne ça c'est moins lui la
métamorphose
voilà et puis alors des ouvrages sur
kafka du style manouche alors c'est vous
maurice nadeau qui avait publié sept
ouvrages conversation avec kafka
c'est tout à fait intéressant est ce que
vous connaissez cet ouvrage vous
connaissez aussi c'est oui en anglais
alors un classique évidemment c'est le
caf cas de max brod bros de bordj peu
comme on dit aux éditions idée gallimard
le clos soit jeunes bac alors a beaucoup
écrit sur gallimard c'est lui qui avait
fait le livre dans la collection
écrivains de toujours
il y a aussi toujours du même qu'aux
jeunes bac alors ça c'est un un album
avec des photos des documents tout à
fait extraordinaire sur kafka vous le
connaissez c'est rageant vous vous le
connaissez tous
marthe robert bien entendu c'est une
spécialiste en spécialiste de kafka en
france publié dans la collection chez
gallimard pour une bibliothèque idéale
et puis enfin ben je remonterai qu'un
pourquoi en avoir deux le corps dans la
fête le corps dans la tête par don de
kafka par sur kafka pas glisser dans les
vies et serge sabinus aux éditions
scarabées et compagnie voilà ce qu'a ce
cas voilà si vous voulez probablement
pas lu voilà eh bien merci à tous les
trois jeux montré beaucoup de deux
ouvrages mais il est vrai que sur les
grands écrivains
il est normal que les critiques écrivent
beaucoup bonsoir à tous et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]